Good
morning. We're back live.
today. May I be forgiven for skipping
leg
day, at least temporarily.
Uh, okay. Let's take a look at some of
the experiments that we ran
overnight. Looks like it crashed at 167.
So, that is
odd. We We will check on that.
Looks like we have a number of
reasonable runs
solve. And then
oops, got relative times.
uh that
are about
23 23 seconds or so. 23 25 seconds for a
solve. Pretty
good. Pretty pretty
good. And then before we go into the
uh actual real analysis for
this. Oh yeah.
Okay. That's pretty damn good.
So our sweep algorithm is really doing
things once
again. These are quite nice
80%. So I think then what we will do
today we're going to start off with a
bit of analysis of these experiments.
We're going to see if uh optimal
hyperparameters have changed quite a bit
or not. See what has happened in that
area.
and then we will see where we go from
there. A lot of different potential
things to do
today. I've not actually used this
interface in quite a while. Good to be
back to this. So, yeah, here if we see
this, this chart shows us how well runs
we're doing uh over the course of the
sweep. You can see we get some middling
ones early on, then we kind of latch on
and they get really good by the
end. We're still running a range of
different costs of experiments, which is
what we would want.
Good to little time
steps ranging
from like 40ome mil or no 50some mil up
to 100 mil.
And with batch sizes not really being
explored very much, which is a little
odd. I'm just looking if there's
anything super weird
here before we uh we go to the other
lambda. We've got horizon num ms. We
didn't sweep this at all intentionally.
So, this is going to stay
here. Yeah. Then the costs are actually
quite well
distributed. We get value
coefficient. So, these sweeps all look
reasonable. Now, if we can get the uh
where is it? Sample. This one.
This is going to show us like hyperp
robustness. So this looks quite good,
right? That we have these
runs. We can solve with a pretty wide
range. But you know, I actually I think
I want to filter this to be under 40
seconds
maybe because the thing is like you
could have really good runs that still
just take forever. But why don't we
filter this to
be I think that there are plenty of runs
here under 35 seconds,
right? Even under 30 seconds.
No, cuz they take a while to eval. So,
we'll do 40
do 45 since there's a startup time with
All
right.
97 results that are less than 45
seconds. Let's see if we're happy with
this filter.
I think we could be a little bit more
aggressive on this,
right? I mean, it's kind of hard to say
cuz some of these eval are so
long. Maybe we'll go with this for
now. Okay.
MIT has finals this week. No
idea. Uh MIT is semester system, I
believe. Uh Stanford is quarter system,
different. I much preferred the um the
trimester system. I will
say like the the quarter system.
semester is just too
long. Like if you get behind in anything
on week eight, you're screwed.
Okay, so this still looks relatively
like
stable and like the gamma range is still
relatively
stable and lambda is so like I this is
confirming what I was thinking of like
it seems like the hyper pram ranges are
just way more stable
uh than they used to
be with the new optimizer and all the
new stuff we've
done. There are some new parameters we
have to check. Okay, so here's Adam beta
1. Again, we're getting good runs
anywhere from 0.9 to
0.98 beta
So we're seeing like not much
dependence at all on
these. Let's add some new scatters for
the new
metrics. IO
be train total time steps.
Why does this not have Yeah, there it
is.
Last
four. So, here's pryo
alpha. Uh, I totally messed up this
axis. Hang on.
The x- axis should supposed to
be alpha. There we
go. Doesn't look like there's a huge
amount of dependence on
this. We didn't really expect it to for
this end.
And interestingly, there doesn't seem to
be very much dependence here
either. You solve with
because these do uh very different
things.
Well, I suppose what we can do now,
right, is we can really just tune this
into
seconds. Okay, so now we're at 65 items.
These are now like the better
experiments. We still don't really see
any
anywhere. So I guess it means that like
any of these hyperparameters
individually can be
robust. So like kind of any value of any
of these hyperparams individually is not
enough to break it. which is kind of
weird because this is definitely not how
RL worked a few months ago. So, this has
got to be a result of um all the new
tuning that we did. I mean, all the new
algorithm stuff that we did to enable
the
tuning is quite good.
So,
um, what I think we do next
is let's pick like a few good runs that
we we know we like
here. Actually, I don't necessarily even
want this filter anymore,
right? Yeah, because like they're
actually they're runs up here or
whatever that they stretch
farther. But this one is
good. Uh the I really wish you could
click on a
run. Can we get that uh Neptune? It's
like very silly that we can't do that.
Like there's not a good way to sort
through these at all.
27346 is a very good one. Right.
mil 20
one. And do we
have guess there's like this purple one
underneath of it? That looks pretty
good. Oh, yeah. There's this green one
here. This like
lime green. We probably want this one.
here. The purple one actually looks
higher in this
375. I'm just trying to get like a few
of the
better the better runs
here. And let's get like one more
27371. Just a little bit under.
Yeah. So, these are the runs we're going
to pick for our little bit of analysis
here. And I just want to see like of the
top runs kind of like what's the spread
in uh in hypers.
Like the idea is any of these do pretty
well
individually? Like do they have similar
hypers? Is this still a
range or what's going on here? And then
we'll see if we can reproduce all of
these or if they're like no tricky to do
that. Okay, so learning rate anywhere
from
01 to
07. So that's like a 2x range. It's
pretty reasonable.
Oh, I don't like this one actually. Hang
on. Let's get a different run. I don't
like I don't like this run that didn't
quite converge.
yet? We have this one. This was the best
one.
I wish um this is just like a missing
Neptune feature that should like you
should just be able to click on
this or at least see the names correctly
when you hover over them.
This one's not
bad.
297. And this converges nicely. Okay,
cool. I'm happy with this. And uh you
know what I'm going to do? I'm going to
just post this real quick.
200. Is that 10 billion steps of
breakout? Hang on. 50 mil five bill like
10 bill steps of breakout.
right. The learning rate
here is anywhere from 0.01 to 0.017.
you actually you get like a reasonable
range
here. And actually, I'm going to take
some notes down to like do these
again because um this is kind of what
I'm going to do for the
final
analysis of all this stuff for the
release.
You'll get a quick preview then
of of
this re-release
analysis run
sweeps pick
top
best
curves
wise ram ranges for
these. Uh probably
do breakout snake
maze
three like one more tower
climb maybe something like
that. We'll see which ones we use. I
think that's going to be a good
start. Okay.
The learning rate has roughly stable
regime factor of almost
is gamma is actually pretty
tight. Gamma is actually pretty tight
here if you know you look at it this
way. I guess we did only take like the
top
few, but like there really only are a
few like really good ones in here. So
gamma is constrained from
974 to
985. So there's like a pretty narrow
range for that.
Actually, we could also ablate these,
right? That's actually another idea.
I think we're going to have to do two
M's for
that maze. I'm glad I made that maze
environment. It's been very, very
useful.
Okay, so lambda lambda is way way more
robust as we expect here, right? So this
is 84 to 96. Lambda doesn't really seem
to matter that
much. We did not sweep up to 80
pucks. Value coefficient is actually
these runs are all in a pretty narrow
range as well.
here and
then entropy
coefficient. Okay, it actually does get
some entropy now. I didn't do this
before. I don't
here. And then we have sweep
progress. Oh, that's
nothing. This batch size didn't get
changed. Total time steps. Okay, this is
interesting. Anywhere from 65 million to
100 million.
So some of these would just be slower
than others,
right? I guess what we can do is we can
like
look. Oh, it's just the analysis at the
end. You see there's like this massive
post
analysis like it's not really doing
anything here. It's already trained.
Yeah. So these are actually like these
are all done
at about the same time, right? This is
where they're done. And if we do
like real time here, right? If we do
real time and we just check here, it's
they're done at 25 seconds. Definitely
by 30
I am curious on Okay, they all use the
same mini batch
size. We did sweep mini batch size,
didn't
batch. Yeah, we totally swept mini
batch, right? It's just this is the best
one. It's up to 16K, which is twice what
it used to be in our old version. And
you could not get better than uh 8192
for breakout. So this is
Okay.
Um ah this tells a different story here.
All right. Now we have a pretty narrow
range
of atom beta
1 narrowish range and atom beta
Alpha. Okay. Pryo doesn't seem to
be mattering a ton here or here. It's a
little
works. Uh I didn't expect it to matter a
ton here though. I'm a little surprised
at how much it doesn't matter, but we
will see. I'm not going to judge this
until we see the maze results. The maze
results are the ones where we would
expect this to really matter. If it
doesn't matter there then something is
up. Mind you this prioritize replay is
one small portion of the sampling
algorithm.
here. The first thing is we're going to
pick one of
these. I think we are going to pick the
probably this dark one here which is
what's this
numbered
What I want to do is first see if this
run uh replicates appropriately. I
really need to make a better way of
copying settings over.
So, this thing actually has a
ridiculously high learning rate now,
right?
I am curious to see if this works for
other M. This is like a ludicrously high
learning
alpha actually. That does wait. O no,
this is mind alpha. Okay, that's
actually interesting,
right? I think I read the chart wrong
Interesting. I mean, that does tell you
something,
right? Because
um it's basically trying to not use this
parameter, but the other runs where it
is using it still work.
mil. So doesn't really do any more uh
sample efficiency, but that's fine. We
did not tune it for sample
efficiency. We do have the ability to
tune for sample efficiency with the
exact same algorithm.
And then we did not sweep any NFS. So if
I let if I did not miss anything here,
this should work. Hey,
welcome. How's it going,
mark.
Um, it's just not
Wrong
branch. That's
this I've seen you in here.
Welcome
back. Okay, there we
go. Now we just
grab token and we see if we basically
just see if this run matches.
So, 25 second solve on a slightly faster
machine. We're training 2.3 mil steps
per second.
Yeah. So, 26 27 on the slightly slower
machine. Very reasonable. And then done
training in
30-ish.
Mhm. Okay. Those are good
settings. Yeah, those are good settings.
I guess
like how robust is this
thing? If I just like start grabbing
parameters from
other other runs like are they all
highly correlated or not?
like there were training uh learning
rates up
to.17 right so if I just do this is this
still
Yeah, that's about the exact like almost
exactly the same as before,
right? Final eval is almost
identical. And
then if I go like outside of this range
maybe
I'm just trying to get a sense of how
correlated these all
are. There's probably a way better way
to do this automatically, which I should
do for release.
Okay. So, this does do worse, right? So,
if I go outside of the range of the
sweeps, you see here, it's not like it's
not working. It is working, but it's
going to take longer. So, anything in
the range uh specified is fine, which
actually is interesting
because this uh this range like the low
end of this range is twice as high as I
had previously. Probably because of the
mini batch size. It doubles mini batch
size, so it doubles learning
works. Slightly
lower. Are these general sweeps? You're
trying to sort of get a strong baseline.
Captain, I'm trying to see ascertain
hyper pram robustness in general. So,
first thing is we didn't really do a
proper sweep for the uh the latest
version of the code. So, I'm doing that.
See if anything has uh has shifted. And
then from there,
um, we're going to see like diff across
different M's if the optimals are
substantially different. So I have this
sweep to analyze right now and then I
have the maze sweep to analyze and we're
going to see how those two are
This one was higher, right?
973. What if I do
that? Maybe. I just want to see how like
how accurate these counts
are. Like, does it go higher if I go
towards this end of the pram range?
I don't mind really. I don't mind just
playing around with a bunch of
experiments when they're this fast,
right?
Okay, that actually replicates like
really really well. This is slightly
better. Like if I were looking for
defaults that don't look insane, right?
I could do something like
this. And then where's
gamma? Where was it?
We're going to just test like the major
ones like entropy and stuff like that
out.
doesn't seem like it
is. This is
this. We want to make sure we're not
also just looking at seed varants here,
right? We're not going to do this level
of manual fiddling for the maze that
takes forever.
But it is useful once in a while to like
get a sense of how robust your RL
feels. Okay. 860. So yeah, that is back
to being correct. So let's see now if I
just make a very small adjustment. So
this will change like the seating and
very little
else. I do 85. This
should not have a big swing in it. If we
have a consistent amp and a consistent
training setup and we are
robust, then I don't have to give hyper
pram defaults to like giant string of
digits.
Okay. Yeah, this is very consistent,
which is cool because breakout didn't
used to be, but this is very
consistent. And uh the params aren't
like if you change it a little bit, it
breaks. It's like it's pretty robust
now. Now,
entropy. Actually interested to see
entropy. This is way more entropy than
we've seen
before. Do I not have entropy on
here? I saw it right there. Okay. So,
anywhere
from
02, like
025ish all the way up to
054. So what happens if I use
the first of all what happens if I do
entropy? It's actually kind of better if
it doesn't because then uh we'll have
this as a nice test net for like when we
try to go replace entropy in the next
algorithm block.
we'll have something to go off
of. Okay, you can see that there is a
decent a pretty decent difference,
right?
I mean, they get to very similar places,
but where's the where did the other
curve
go? Yeah. So, this is the new
one. Would it work if you made the
entropy coefficient
negative? I don't know.
I could imagine that messing stuff up
quite
easily. The entropy actually made like
it made it like these curves are
different. It's not hugely important,
but that is a
distinction. That's not just random
noise.
Breakout isn't an M where you'd expect
it to be super important
though. So, it's going to be interesting
to compare these results to the maze. I
do want to paste this because we got
about an hour before breakfast. So, I
want to get both of these analysis
results done before then. Okay. Yeah.
So, it doesn't work with negative
entropy because it just determinizes the
policy, right?
So like you get positive point plus 005
0 and
negative.05. But now between point the
low end of the range here and the high
end of the range can we tell the
actually. Like less exploration at the
start but better convergence. That's
about what we'd
expect. Keep this
In some sweeps I did impulse wars train
much better with very low
entropy. Yeah, I mean I've seen that
too. It's going to it
depends like it just it depends.
These things used to make no sense and
now they're starting to make more sense.
Right?
Yeah, entropy isn't really exploration
though is the thing.
I mean, it's like dollar store
exploration, dime store
explanation. It literally just
encourages the agent to flail about a
bit.
Like, it's not exploration in any
meaningful sense of the word.
So that made a big difference actually
that little tweak to G to uh that made a
big
difference. So this pram actually
matters. We go to 99.
right? No, I wait. I have a mass
of.99 on atom beta
1. It doesn't use it, though.
What happens if I go to point uh
99? Does this like do worse or
There. Okay. So, this is worse,
right? That's why it doesn't go
above. Yeah, that param matters a
lot. Adam beta, but.99 seems
norm. This is one. This one is
potentially interesting, right?
ton? So if it's using
this. Okay. So clip track
here. It's clipping a lot of the
updates. We should suspect this hurts PF
maybe.
all? Actually, that clip track term is
based on KL, I
Yeah. So this pram like doesn't matter
at
highly we know this one's highly
sensitive.
uh we'll do the value function after we
confirm this still works.
And I do want to mess with the
um prioritize Replay.
weighted important sampling
with alpha equals 0 and beta equals
Okay. But we need to look at this at
some point. Then it makes sense I guess
that it
did set this parameter
here. I want to see if uh if it changes
if I set beta equal to one.
Interestingly, o uh zero is a little
worse than
0.1. Oh, no. The eval is the same.
Okay. Logging
differences. What happens if I set this
equal to one?
and then a value function coefficient.
This one should have uh something to it,
sensitivity. Me actually see what the
range was from
here 1.1. Okay, this actually has some
sensitivity to it, right?
This performs substantially
worse. That's way worse. And if I set
this to like 2.5
2.5, but I guess it just can't be too
low. Value loss gets clipped anyways, so
that's probably what's happening
there. Yeah, it works very well at 2.5.
Okay, though. With all this, we have
a we have a good set of
So next we will go to uh the
maze and we will
see how the results over there are
different.
Oops. This next end can show it real
quick.
So this is puffer grid the big maze
environment. It will generate randomized
mazes from very small to the size of
this
window. And this is a very hard
environment for RL and only see a small
window around itself. Um this is
generally a very difficult benchmark for
RL to solve.
results. Uh and I can actually see that
this this kept running. Yeah, this is
still running stuff. Cool. It did not
crash. Even better. Uh so now this is
what we were more expecting, right? Now
this like we actually get some way
stronger looking dependence. So for a
more complex N it seems that we get a a
way clearer correlation with the hyper
prams and we see
gamma here we see our learning rate
banded
there learning rate's very different
from um breakout but also the network
size is very different
so
lambda value function way higher. Okay,
so this is actually in line with what we
were seeing with the higher value
function
coefficient max gradient
norm seem to
We do go up and up in total time steps
potentially
here. Best results obtained at very
small mini batch
size.
Interesting. We have our atom beta
1 which actually this is a different
range than uh the other
Uh, and
here here this matters a ton, right?
Look at that. The prioritized replay
matters a
there. All right. So, so far this sweep
is like the best thing I could have
possibly asked
for. We're very happy with
this. So, we have these scores like
this. Not very many good runs. If you
look at it in this way, we go on a uh
relative time axis
where does it show priority buffer helps
a ton. So what you do for that captain
is you look at these graphs and then you
look at uh you plot on the x-axis the
hyperp and on the y- axis the score and
then you can see across 170 some odd
runs the only good runs ever had very
high uh priority alpha coefficient. You
see so this is one of the sensitivity
analysis tools I like to use.
Like similarly, right? You can
see like the correlation here with
um like the value function coefficient
for
instance. Now what we do is we go grab a
few runs and uh we look more closely
Captain, I've been making progress.
We've been making heck of a lot of
progress in
here. Better be with the amount I work
on this stuff.
I think this is going to take me longer
than the next 35 minutes though to
finish. We will
see. We need this brown curve.
But we need this brown curve.
Dude, this is literally reminding me of
the
um the Uncle Bob like closure isn't
fast. I was able to hit 20 frames per
second on my little game I built with
it. Like Neptune is really fast. It's
like so many times faster than wanni.
Yeah, it's still
slow. Still freaking
slow. We should be sad that software is
like this
nowadays. All right, so these actually
these are pretty
nice. Why don't we like just tune this
to like
use. It's 300 million steps of training.
You can see we get pretty good
performance from 200
mil. And on a relative time
axis, these
are six to 10 minute
experiments. Put sleep tariffs on Python
imports. That's funny.
You don't need the thing is the sad
thing is you don't need to put sleep
tariffs on Python imports cuz some of
them already take two seconds to import
a damn
package. It's like crazy that like
people do not realize that software
literally used to be a thousand times
faster. Like I opened on um brand new
like Windows machine, highest end specs
possible. Open a any application takes
three seconds. Open like brand new Mac,
you know, new app, open an application
takes 3 seconds.
Like it's
ridiculous. One, two. That's at least
better, but that's still embarrassing.
Should be instantaneous. No reason it
shouldn't be.
30 seconds if it's intentional
software. No, it feels to me like most
developers are trying to do
that. Okay. So, we get this nice band
range
here. Band range here. very close gamma
to what we happen to have for breakout
which is kind of
lambda. Uh the tax for Electron is um if
you write an Electron app, you're just
like banned from writing software
because like what are you doing?
You're just banned. Ah, shoot. You know,
I didn't realize that we had update
epoch set to
two. So, I got to rerun this sweep with
update epox one. It'll probably be
faster. Oh, actually, this looks like it
swept update epochs.
I think we just grab this policy to
start
with. We just like grab this
policy and then we
Like honestly, if I wanted to make a
competitor for like either of these
apps, Captain, I'd just be like, "What
if we wrote the front end in array lib
in
C?" Congratulations. All your stuff
responds
instantly. Almost as if you didn't need
that massive stack of dependencies.
There's actually like a kind of a crazy
amount of
um there's like kind of a crazy amount
of upside these days in just like
knowing what you're doing and
um and writing stuff super lowle because
like think about it, you're going to be
a thousand times faster than anyone
else. It's literally all I did with
Puffer.
uh nobody else is going to be able to
like remotely do what you're doing
because freaking nobody knows how to
write anything that isn't like
Typescript
anymore. So like pretty much no matter
what you do in your fancy framework,
you're never going to match perfwise and
you're going to spend a ton of effort
trying to match that
perf. kind of like a reasonable thing to
do these days, especially with people
like just making more and more bad
software like quicker and quicker with
AI. It's like kind of the way to go is
to actually build stuff correctly and
then you know you just you get the
massive quality
Uh, this was actually only two four.
This is only 250 mil
steps. I think it didn't even need to be
that long,
right? We don't forget update
epochs two.
And then EF coefficient is
massive massive value function
coefficient. Cool. Don't think I forgot
anything. I kind of just went down the
line so it should be
good.
Yep. Cool. So we will see
uh whether this does anything
mazes. So 80% solve.
If you're assuming that you're always
solving like the easiest like the
smallest mazes first, I believe
66% would be that you're solving always
like 32 by 32. So this is better than an
algorithm that just solves like 32x 32
mazes. This is probably a very very very
good
agent. Kind of cool.
Okay, so this is already at 7.
That's kind of
crazy to have
um this 100 million steps and that's
like wrecking our previous best policy
by a
mile. And I shouldn't I should say more
than this is just better than our
previous best policy. Uh I don't think
anything else is remotely close on any
similar task in RL overall.
result. So, I guess what I want to do
while we're waiting for this, we got
another 20
minutes. This was the best one
here. Best one
had this learning
rate. I'm just looking for like anywhere
where one of these params seems like the
other ones suggest it could be done
better. Value function coefficient just
keeps going up and
up. Actually suggest that like the
clipping param would be the one to look
at.
Oops. The beta actually made a big
difference over here.
So, the two things I'm seeing
potentially are the atom beta
1 and the
um clipping
So, this actually does look like pretty
stable, pretty stable training. It's not
quite log
linear. Um, it does increase though.8
Well, I guess it's actually a little
harder to
say cuz you can complete several short
maps uh in the time that it takes like
to fail on one long
map. But this should be pretty cool
policy to look at.
Hey Tyler,
welcome. We are analyzing a very large
number of
experiments. We got new hypers for
breakout. We solve in about
seconds and we have new state-of-the-art
maze
results. Maze being just
um stand in ludicrously hard RL
task. Well, should be state of the art.
We'll see when we look at this policy in
a
second. 82%
board. Oh, I see what you mean.
Gotcha.
Cool. Something similar. We should have
something similar to Montazuma's
revenge. I mean, you could go implement
it to be fair. It would take a bit.
I mean, honestly, like
just you know who you should chat with?
You should chat with Ryan cuz
like Ryan wants to really get Net Hack
working. Um, they're just some really
obnoxious infrastructure problems with
like getting Net Hack to run really
well. Um, and the thing is like you're
never going to make like a rogike
dungeon crawler type thing that's
anywhere near the complexity of Net
Hack. But I wonder if like just the
exploration art of Net Hack of like
having to get through like a big rogike
dungeon if we could add that to Puffer
Grid. It would just be like a new map
gengo, right? Like if you made like um
connect interconnected rooms
uh terrain gen algorithm, then instead
of explore maze, it could be explore
like maze of rooms or
whatever. And then that would be
interesting to see if you get like
coherent roomto room travel just
emergent like it learns to never just
run around in the middle of a room for
no reason.
Okay. Well, that doesn't seem amazing,
but this is a really unlucky seed. Look
at this. You go down here and then
you're just totally
stuck. Come on. There you
go. Oh, that was good backtracking.
The really long-term backtracking is
still
hard. This is like a really Some of
these bigger mazes have really hard
seeds. Look, this one is all wrong. And
like this one should be easy enough,
right? It'll get this one. Yeah.
scattered. This does actually have keys
implemented, captain. You can do locked
rooms in this
maison. It'd be actually pretty easy to
build stuff on top of this. I was trying
to make like
a decent like grid thing without making
it too
enginey. This policy can still
definitely be better though.
this. Not bad though. It's just like
sucks that it has to go all the way back
here. It's kind of doing like local
backtracking, right?
Like it'll backtrack 10 20
steps. But if it's on the other side of
the map, it's just not going to do
it. Like fair play. That's really hard
to
learn. Oh, wait. It got it. I didn't
even see the
solution. Nope. No reason, Captain. We
should uh we should randomize it. I just
haven't
bothered. This is actually if you want
to do well you should absolutely get
impulse force thing first but like this
is a really good M if you want to like
just a solid research task like this is
a really good M to do stuff
with. Okay.
So, get a couple ideas with
It is possible the combination of very
high value coefficient and clip is going
to screw it
up. I had some earlier tests suggesting
that VF clip was that way too low.
This curve seems to be very similar
though is somewhat disappointing.
alpha. Hang on.
We had pryo alpha. Oh yeah, the atom
for.99 was better for
this. Let's try
that. First of all, let's see is this
doing
anything? Nope. Same curve. So, we don't
need to mess with the value function
clip coefficient
here. We do want to mess with this
optimizer
coefficient. So, we'll run this for a
couple minutes and then I will go grab
breakfast and then I will be back
afterwards and we will be continuing to
work
on probably getting a bunch of new
sweeps launched, sweeps analysis.
Um, general cleanup, GPU drive, new M's
cabin. It would be a good idea to start
getting uh Impulse Wars stuff training
nicely in a release soon as
well. We should definitely do
that because like in my
mind, we need good end
benchmarks. We need good sweeps. I need
to keep cleaning up the code a little
bit more. And then we're pretty close to
release. I'm just doing that
Okay, this seems
um seems
worse. It makes sense. You trust the
sweep,
right? If you
do take off
streams, sweeps on impulse. Yeah, I it's
worth sweeping for
sure. I don't know. It's It's pretty
likely at this point that we just like
just sweeping stuff kind of solves a lot
of
it. You
Okay, I'm going to go for uh for
breakfast and I will be back afterwards
working on all sorts of RL stuff for the
whole rest of the day thereafter. So uh
for the folks watching this is all free
and open source software. You can help
me out for free just by starting the
repo. Are we at 2K or is it rounded
still? I really would like to hit 2K
today. Two stars. If two people watching
this star it, we'll hit 2K right now,
which would be
awesome. Puffer.ai/puffer on GitHub. Uh,
also linked from puffer.ai.
If you want to get involved with
development, join the Discord. It's
discord.gg/puffer. It's also on here.
And um most of our top contributors came
in with zero RL background whatsoever.
So, we make it pretty easy to get on
board and it's a great way to learn
stuff in AI and RL specifically. Other
than that, you can follow me on X for
more RL content. So, thanks and I will
be back after breakfast, probably about
an hour. Five.